more outrage over the soft-handed
approach to violent crime new video
showing the heartbreaking moment when a
six-month-old baby boy was killed in a
car crash in Chicago so the two
teenagers accused of stealing the car
that caused the wreck are only facing
misdemeanor charges and the victim's
family is slamming the charges as
disheartening to say the least so where
does it end will liberal comic Bill
Maher is wondering why the media won't
address the crime crisis in cities like
Chicago
I was reading that in New York a third
of all the shoplifting cases are by 327
people
in a city of 8 million
because they keep getting returned to
the streets like Chicago like most of
the the shootings are young black men
killing other young black men is that
not correct why doesn't anybody talk
about that well I mean why aren't there
you know a
100 giant black celebrities who would
have the respect of those people saying
what are you doing to yourselves why are
you killing each other
even outgoing Chicago mayor Lori
Lightfoot is admitting that her party
has a crime problem in Liberal cities
that needs to be addressed
if we do not speak the truth about
violent crime in our city we will be the
worst for it but I know that there are
people in my city that are wreaking
havoc every day and need to be off the
street we say yeah the police department
is spending all this time and resources
to arrest put a case on and then the
judges and the prosecutors say you know
what we're going to let you out on
electronic monitoring to wreak havoc
again
welcome to the five Lori Lightfoot um
okay do you remember and there was an ad
between I can't remember it was UPS or
FedEx and This Woman's very frustrated
in a meeting because she says something
and then the the guy says it next to her
and he's the the boss says yeah with it
I'm with him and she's like I just said
that I sort of feel like that because
when Bill Maher says why isn't anybody
talking about this it's just that if we
say it nobody listens no it's funny this
is probably the third or fourth like
major story that we have been following
for years that we've been talking about
relentlessly and it never gets covered
because oh it's Fox News oh it's the
five and it's amusing to see the level
of surprise uh over something that we've
been hammering for years but finally the
truth it seems like the truth has been
set free it's out of its Silo uh uh and
the problem is what kind of result do
you get out of that and oftentimes we
know what the result is we get called
racist right and the irony of that is a
racist wouldn't want to talk about black
on black crime because they just wanted
to continue right you know it's like
it's like it doesn't make any sense but
they will call you a racist for bringing
it up that leads me to the question why
does the left not want to talk about it
and I believe it's because the reason if
you have to talk about it then you have
to have solutions for it being fixed and
that's where the left runs into problems
because at that point they have to they
have they need
the hard-line products need to listen to
solutions from the other side uh because
they have a long history of working
people on the right we understand you
may hate the right but they're really
good on Law and Order let's be honest
you guys are good with compassion you
know we're good with conduct and so you
get but unfortunately this is these are
one party towns where you need two
parties and that one party that's in
control doesn't have the spine to go
after crime hence Lori Lightfoot finally
coming out and saying it after she's
leaving and after she lost yeah after
she lost so Harold and I mean you've
also said similar things that we have
said but when Bill Maher says it does
will that make a difference I hope I
think that that bill probably should
listen to our show uh and listen to us
at Fox I think crime is bad regardless
of where it's committed we've seen the
last several days you had a young 16
year old kid go to the door to pick up
his siblings he was shot uh you had a 20
year old uh woman uh driving the wrong
driveway realize she was in the wrong
drive and she's backing out she got shot
a six-year-old kid with his dad playing
ball in the backyard something's wrong
something's wrong with us also when
these kinds of things happen and I
appreciate when any and everyone wants
to focus on this with the energy that
Bill is saying but we talk about this
every day and for me this is not a
racial issue but when you inject race
into it the communities that get hit the
hardest that suffer the most Greg says
it often Greg's not a racist he talks
about race a lot but he's not racist at
all he talks about it because no but you
when you talk about when you're talking
about race in these issues it's not a
racist no these are just facts in the
communities that get hit the hardest are
most of the time unfortunately
regrettably communities of color Larry
Lightfoot came around I wish she had
said some of these things when she was
mayor was she acted on some of this as
mayor but I'm a Believer when you get a
convert you take them and I'm hopeful
that if she decides to re-enter politics
if my friend over here to the right yeah
when she comes around you got to accept
people who come to yourself let me tell
you something about her this woman is a
former Federal prosecutor she knew this
when she was the mayor so don't give me
me this thank God she came around
no but she was so beholden to the
progressives and to the left that people
died because of that mentality that
social justice nonsense and first of all
she didn't just figure this out she's
known it and she went against her core
being to allow these social justice
Warriors criminals to be out again and
again and what I want to know is did she
have a lobotomy I mean what is different
she was a pro-crime ignore crime social
justice Warrior to the to the detriment
of thousands and thousands of minority
men women and children so and just so
you all know black on black crime is
something everyone in law enforcement
knows about this is nothing new for any
of us that's why we have Street crimes
you Street crime units that's why we
have Inner City crime units that's why
we have a stop in choir and frisk all
that stuff is justified by Terry versus
Ohio until the social justice Warriors
and oh that's not right but the people
who are being harmed are the people in
the inner city and by the way there's a
reason people are leaving Chicago
there's a reason people are leaving
Illinois and one of the reasons so many
young blacks are involved in crime is
nobody's keeping them in schools and as
a mayor she had nothing to do with it
what you've got now is many of the Black
American youths 85 percent of black
students in the eighth grade lack the
ability to do math and are functionally
illiterate so it's not just about
locking them up it's about making sure
they stay in school so that they have a
reason so they have hope and we
mentioned Susan Rice who was leaving the
White House domestic policy Council head
chair of Education they never talk about
it at the White House either the crime
or education no if you're going to have
a complete discussion about how to deal
with this you have to talk about
education but you also need to talk
about single parent households you need
to talk about the the destruction of
marriage in this country and if you you
don't start talking about that and
families and the role that dads play in
this then you're not going to actually
complete the discussion and the left
doesn't even want to begin to do that
let alone get in there and talk about
the veracity and the the need for the
Second Amendment so that people can
actually protect themselves they're
trying to do everything they can to to
get rid of guns and what about all the
people what about that single 18 year
old girl who's just trying to get her
education or go to work don't you feel
for how is she going to protect herself
in these in these radical cities where
there's no crime prevention there's
there's not a cop on the beat or
somebody on the street to protect her
they don't ever tell those stories I
think it's too late as the judge is
saying she had the opportunity she was
in a position of power and she did the
exact opposite of what what needed to
happen and what happens in our political
system she lost look I just never give
up on people if we give up on people
We're Not Gonna but do you think she
lost because in crime she did it went
further to the left
in the primary and then she didn't get
to the runoff
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now